Oliver Twist was born in a workhouse in 1830s England.
His mother died very soon after, and Oliver went to a badly - run home for orphans.
Nine years later, he was transferred to a workhouse for adults.
He was eventually sold off as an apprentice to a local undertaker,...
...but ran away and traveled toward London.
He met Jack Dawkins, a boy his own age, who worked for Fagin.
Fagin was a criminal who taught young orphan boys to pickpocket.
A sickly and feverish Oliver was caught while stealing a handkerchief from Mr. Brownlow.
Rather than pressing charges, Brownlow took Oliver home and nursed him back to health.
Two young adults in Fagin's gang, Bill and his lover Nancy,...
...captured Oliver and returned him to Fagin.
In a burglary attempt, Oliver was shot, then taken in by the woman of the house.
Her name was Mrs. Maylie and she lived with her beautiful, adopted niece, Rose.
Fagin and Monks wanted to recapture Oliver.
Nancy told Rose of the plan.
In the meantime, Mr. Brownlow confronted Monks...
...and found out that Monks was Oliver's half-brother.
Their father was unhappily married to a wealthy woman and had an affair with Oliver's mother.
Monks had pursued Oliver to ensure that Oliver would never receive his share of the family inheritance.
Brownlow forced Monks to sign over to Oliver, his rightful share.
Moreover, it turned out that Rose was Oliver's aunt.
Fagin was hanged for these crimes. Finally, Brownlow adopted Oliver and they,...
...along with the Maylies, moved to the countryside.